Vicky is with us in Houston Texas hi
Vicki welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up in your world well I have
question here lately I've listened to
you a couple years and purchased a book
and read it well if I got my husband on
board he's kind of really serious about
it now I'm trying to put pen to paper
and really baby step to for me if you'd
because that snowball amount is big a
lot of that and it's literally four
items the largest thing is being my
student loan the other is like $10,000
RS debt that we just found out about he
has a small student loan balance about
$8,000 maybe 10 because he paid for his
schooling a vehicle for 31 and then my
student loan is 134 it's like
overwhelming yeah okay and what's your
household income this year it was with
me - okay awesome what do you do I am a
principal and he's a pharmacist okay
excellent
so the 131 you went back got your
masters and so forth then yeah okay
great and writer says you've got a great
income thanks Dave
and the bad news is you're in a big hole
yeah so I've got a big shove on a big
hole and we got to get to shoveling but
let's pretend that the average household
income makes $50,000 a year in America
which they do okay if you lived on that
on that - 22 - 50 leaves me at 172 is
that where you are yes sir
that's debt free in a year and I
literally have this tablet and they're
like tons of tons of different ways I've
tried to work this and I'm just like it
just feels overwhelming looking at the
student loan balance yeah but did you
hear what I just said yes I heard you
and I want you to tell me how cut your
lifestyle to nothing
and you may need to sell a goofy car if
you can't get traction but thirty-one
thousand dollar car jumped out at me til
you told me 222 was the income and it
doesn't bother me so much now and I'll
be honest we were still driving a car
there was a 95 until last year yeah that
was a 1995 vehicle until last year when
it just a kaput so I think what you guys
have got to do is you have to come
meant to this to the point that you're
willing to cut your lifestyle you need
to live like somebody who makes fifty or
sixty thousand dollars a year and it's
probably actually going to after taxes
everything else probably gonna take you
about two years but I think you could be
completely debt-free in two years but
I'm talking about you have no freakin
life Vicki for that two years you are
not going on vacation and I don't want
to hear about you eating out and I'm
sorry if you're tired call the
wambulance we're going to eat at home
and we're going to clean up this freakin
mess the more intense and passionate you
are
the deeper you cut and the deeper you
cut the faster you get out that's the
formula it's a pretty simple math
formula really and and you know if you
want to play with a little bit and
lighten up a little bit I mean take
three years and get out that's not the
end of the world
anything past three years I'm gonna
start calling you a wuss though okay so
three years or less you should be debt
free so you told me a hundred and thirty
and eight and ten and thirty-one yes and
so I got less than two hundred thousand
dollars in debt for somebody making two
hundred and twenty two thousand dollars
a year how much is your house payment
18:51 that's not a killer that's good
okay
this is doable when you sit down and put
those numbers together I can see them in
my head because I've done this a while
but um you lay those numbers down if
you're willing to give up your little
life for a little while then you can get
your life back for the rest of the time
if you live like no one else later you
can live and give like no one else but
that's what it comes down to so honestly
I you know if you want the let me throw
it at you another way I'm just throwing
fastballs across the middle okay okay if
you want the feeling of being
overwhelmed and stuck in a student loan
debt that seems like it will never go
away the way to fix that feeling is to
explode into this with radical extremism
to knock it out really really fast and
when you start feeling yourself getting
traction and living on that written plan
and you and your husband are saying hey
we're not doing this we're getting out
of that we're not doing that we're
getting out of that we're not doing
ABCDEF
we're not doing XYZ we're not doing any
of those things we're getting out of
that we're paying off our debt we're
doing this and well we're not buying
that we're getting out of that now we'll
just have to repair that thing we can't
get a new one we're going we're getting
out of debt and and you start just doing
that over and over and over and over
again you know you're going to get sick
of the clearance rack you're going to
get sick of the the back corner of the
grocery store where the deals are I mean
you're going to you're going to really
lean into this thing and act like you
are someone who makes a whole lot less
than you make and throw that difference
at the debt when you do that you won't
be overwhelmed anymore because you're
going to be empowered and you're going
to feel like you've got control and then
you're going to call me back into a debt
free scream
you